lieber Herr Calmund ich frage mich
natürlich als leidenschaftlicher
Fußballfan warum sie dem Leverkusener
Verein den Rücken gekehrt haben bitte
bitte kommen Sie wieder zurück und
setzen Sie bitte ein Freundschaftsspiel
gegen den SSC Neapel meinen persönlichen
Lieblingsverein an dann kann ich den SSC
Neapel auch hier mal in Deutschland
vielleicht in Leverkusen sehen vielen
Dank ja es in Neapel der Club von
Maradona der auch viele Erfolge in
Italien eine ganz Europa hatte ich würde
mich persönlich sehr freuen wenn es in
absehbarer Zeit wieder ein
internationales Pflichtspiel also Eva
gab oder Euro Cup Spiel geben würde
zwischen Bayer Leverkusen und Neapel in
dem kommenden Jahr wird's nicht mehr
funktionieren das wissen wir beide ja in
Leverkusen werde ich auch nicht mehr auf
die Kommando Bühne klettern ich habe das
zwei vier gesagt Schluss es Schluss
Feierabend und bin da eigentlich zwei
wie Konrad Adenauer der immer gesagt hat
was stört mich mein Geschwätz von
gestern aber ich will nicht mehr dessen
wo ich den Satz auch nicht zu
strapazieren Fußball lässt nach wie vor
die schönste Sache der Welt ich lieb den
Fußball aber lieber jetzt als Fan und
Zuschauer oder wo ich mich nicht so oft
zu reden